(whooshing)
- [Narrator] "Better than
a thousand hollow words,
is one word", Buddha.
I'm going to share a secret with you,
a secret so powerful that
once you discover it,
every decision you make in your life
and business will become easier.
Doors will start to open
where before you struggled
to make any progress.
You'll finally feel like you're
living your life with a purpose
instead of fighting the world around you.
Great leaders have used this secret
to build powerful companies,
spark important movements,
and create meaningful change.
And now you can too.
Here's the secret,
there is one word that
defines who you are.
There is one word that
connects all the things
in your life that make you come alive.
Think about the friends you
have, the music you listen to,
the books you read, the movies you watch,
the companies you've worked for,
the businesses you've started.
Think about everything in your life
right now that you enjoy.
They're all connected.
Until you figure out
what that connection is,
you'll never live up to your potential.
What's your favorite song
and what does it have to do
with who your best friend
or favorite book is?
The answer is everything.
And it can be boiled down to
one simple, powerful word.
Great people can be described in one word.
Martin Luther King, Jr., equality.
Oprah Winfrey, heart.
Steve Jobs, impact.
How 'about you?
If you want to break free
from the chains of mediocrity
and really make an impact,
then it starts with finding your one word.
You have to stand for something
powerful and important.
(whooshing)